immigration debate is energizing
Americans on all sides of the issue and
we're getting a clearer picture of how
that energy may translate in the midterm
elections the latest CBS News
battleground tracker shows half the
people in the key states of Arizona
Texas and Florida say the family
separation crisis will not change their
vote but voters are worried about
immigration in Arizona 77% feel the
issue is going badly and most say a
candidate has to agree with them on
immigration to get their vote Ed O'Keefe
spoke to four voters in Arizona last
week to see if there's any sign of
political unity on the horizon what do
you think will ultimately perhaps
reunite the country I think that until
we change the narrative of what's
happening when you come out of the gate
saying that people coming from Mexico
are coming here to bring drugs and to
rape people you've already started on
the wrong side of that argument what
might bring us all back to do that
that's his job is to bring the country
together not to separate us no I think
Trump is doing it a lot of people him
blaming the Dems for things is him
uniting the parties I think with the
with the economy going and you see the
people they draws at those rallies those
people are Democrats I think whether
it's Congress or whether its individual
members of political parties everything
isn't like such a sense of gridlock that
it's impossible for people to
communicate ideas respectfully so doing
what we're doing here exactly yeah